Welcome to the James River Church podcast.
You're about to hear another inspirational message from Pastor John Lindell.
Lead pastor at James River Church.
It's our prayer that this message is an encouragement and blessing to your life.
Well, I'm gonna take the next few moments and just finish a message.
I started last week.
There's nothing more important than hearing the voice of God because
That is where direction, that's where faith, that's where so many things happen in our life.
And I would suggest to you, as we said last time, that it's our ability to hear what God is speaking to us in a moment that empowers us in that moment and really can release God's power into the lives of other people.
Granted, God speaks primarily through His word.
So I'm not in any way denying that.
I think everybody understands that I'm a believer in the word of God speaking to us.
And yet I also know this.
I know that you and I need to learn to cultivate a sensitivity, not only to the presence of the Lord, but to the voice of the Lord, because through Him speaking to us, it positions us to minister to other people.
It also positions us to walk out our faith in a practical and a powerful way where other people can see evidence of his supernatural hand on our life and know that there is a God.
So last time we talked about, are you listening?
We have to be listening for the voice of the Lord.
But tonight I wanna talk to you about how to hear God's voice.
And we're gonna look at 1 Samuel chapter three and beginning in verse one.
The boy Samuel ministered before the Lord under Eli.
Eli was the high priest.
Samuel, you remember, had been given by his mother to the Lord because she received him from the Lord.
She brought him to Eli because she and her husband were part of the tribe of Levi, which is the priestly tribe in Israel.
So Eli's there.
He's not his father.
He's biological father.
Eli has two biological sons.
who are thoroughly wicked.
And the Lord places the responsibility for their behavior in part at Eli's feet.
Samuel, on the other hand, is there in the presence of the Lord, even though Eli is not really walking in the presence.
In those days, the word of the Lord was rare, and there were not many visions.
One night, Eli, whose eyes were becoming so weak that he could barely see, was lying down in his usual place.
So remember,
Not many visions, and Eli can't say his physical condition is indicative of his spiritual condition.
The lamp of God had not yet gone out, and Samuel was lying down in the temple of the Lord where the ark of God was.
Then the Lord called Samuel, Samuel answered, here I am.
And he ran to Eli and said, here I am, you called me, but Eli said, I did not call, go back and lie down.
So he went and lay down.
Again, the Lord called Samuel and Samuel got up and went to Eli and said, here I am.
You called me.
My son Eli said, I did not call.
Go back and lie down.
Now Samuel did not yet know the Lord.
The word of the Lord had not yet been revealed to him.
I think this is a very interesting statement in this.
He can hear the word of the Lord, but he doesn't know it's the word of the Lord.
I think that describes a lot of believers.
The Lord is speaking, they just don't recognize He's speaking.
Because He's speaking through a friend, because He's gripping their heart with something, and they haven't yet learned when it is the word of the Lord, when it's the Lord speaking, when it's their own voice speaking.
And so a part of growing in Christ is discerning how God speaks to us
And let me just say this, let me caution everybody because invariably, if you ask somebody, how do you know when it's God speaking?
Everybody kind of has their matrix for how that works in their life.
And yet I caution you because God is never gonna let any of us come to the place where we think we've got him figured out.
About the time you think you got it figured out, God's gonna say, okay, that lesson's done, let's move on and I'm gonna teach you another way I speak.
Because he wants us to grow in our ability to hear him.
So here Samuel, he's just now getting started in the Lord called Samuel a third time.
And Samuel got up, went to Eli and said, here I am, you called me.
Then Eli realized that the Lord was calling the boy.
So Eli told Samuel, go and lie down.
And if he calls you, say, speak, Lord, for your servant is listening.
So Samuel went and laid down in his place.
And the Lord came and stood there calling us at other times, Samuel, Samuel.
Then Samuel said, speak for your servant is listening.
What I want to do is I want to give you seven things that can help us hear from God.
How do we hear from God?
Number one, repentance.
Repentance means
changing the way we think.
It's not so much saying you're sorry, though that could be a part of it, saying you're sorry to God.
It's changing the way you thought.
You thought about something this way, but now you realize no God thinks about it this way.
And so you change your thinking and you change your life.
When we are repenting, we're confessing our sin to God.
So one of the things that keeps people from hearing from God is un-
can fast sin in their life.
So they know they're not right with God.
They know they've allowed things in their life and they're not hearing from God.
And what a lot of people do is they say, well, you know what?
I'm just, I'm not as sensitive as someone so or God doesn't talk to me like he talks to so and so.
Listen, that's not the issue at all.
God speaks all the time.
He talks to people and he wants to talk to everybody in this room, everybody watching online.
He is a God who speaks.
over 3,800 times in the Bible, it references the Lord speaking.
And he speaks to all kinds of people in all kinds of circumstances.
And if you're a Christian, you're his child, he wants to speak to you not once in a while, he wants to speak to you regularly.
So if he's not speaking, the first thing you gotta ask yourself is, are there things in my life that are displeasing to the Lord?
In Eli's situation, imagine this,
The Lord is calling out to Samuel.
Samuel can hear him, but Eli can't.
And even when he knows it's the voice of the Lord, there's no sense in the text that Eli is hearing the voice, only Samuel's hearing it.
And the question is, why can't the high priest hear God's voice?
1 Samuel 2, 22.
Now Eli, who was very old, heard about everything his sons were doing to all Israel, how they slept with the women who served at the entrance to the tent of meeting.
In verse 29, we read this, why do you scorn God sent a prophet to ask him?
Why do you scorn my sacrifice and offering that I prescribed to my dwelling?
In other words, they were going and they were taking the best part of the offering rather than giving it to God.
In verse 30, the Lord says, but now the Lord declares far be it for me.
Those who honor me, I will honor, but those who despise me will be disdain.
What's that saying?
The word is to Eli.
And what the prophet is saying is God is telling you you're not honoring him.
And when you don't honor God with a life of purity, with a life of consecration, with a life of devotion, then you're not going to hear God's voice.
That's the problem for Eli.
1 Samuel 3.13, for I told him I would judge his family forever because of the sin he knew about, his sons made themselves contemptible, and he failed to restrain them.
Parents, you and I have a responsibility to teach our children to train them in the way they're to go and to direct them.
And there are times where you have, as long as they are under your care, under your roof, and you have an accountability to restrain them from evil.
And in Eli's case, he doesn't do it.
And the result is he's not honoring God.
Therefore, God is not honoring him by speaking to him.
It's not even that he can't hear God's voice in one sense it is because God is speaking to Samuel.
Eli knows what it is, but can't hear it for himself.
But God is not speaking to Eli because Eli has unconfessed sin in his life.
And remember when we're talking about the toleration of sin in our life, we have to be very, very careful because the time to stop sin is when it first appears.
Because most sin comes by way of fleshly desire.
In other words, it comes out of our own humanity.
But when sin is repeated, we've opened then at that point the door to the enemy, to the devil.
And now it becomes demonically energized through our toleration of it.
It becomes demonically energized in a person's life.
And at that point, it becomes much more difficult to eradicate and impossible without repentance.
If you have unrepentant sin in your life, you're not gonna hear the voice of the Lord.
This is what David writes in Psalm 66 verse 18.
If I had cherished sin in my heart, the Lord would not have listened.
He's not only going to not listen, you're not going to hear him speak.
My concern for a lot of people is that they have this idea, well, you know what, when it comes to repentance, I'm gonna go ahead and do this, and then I'll ask God to forgive me, and they're banking on the opportunity to repent, not realizing that repentance is a gift from God.
It is not initiated by you, it is initiated by the Holy Spirit working in your heart.
You and I, on our own, would never repent.
The Holy Spirit is the one who works that in the life of the believer, and if he doesn't work that, if God does not give you the gift of repentance, you will not repent and you will die in your sin, or you will be trapped in your sin.
This is why it's really critical that you and I, not only we start a Christian life with repentance, but we walk it out with a continued repentance that helps us maintain a close relationship with God.
So in some ways, repentance is a lifestyle where we're constantly aligning ourselves with God's thinking.
And the result is,
that when you and I repent, we'll hear God's voice.
Because the prompting to repent tense is the fact that you are hearing his voice.
If you have a desire to repent, it's because you're hearing his voice.
A woman came up, I was standing after the album, and a woman came up, and she said, I need to repent.
And I said, oh, and then we had this discussion.
And I have leadership posts there who were able to help me to pray.
And then she was from another, she was from the Joplin area.
And fortunately the Joplin pastor was there and I was able to connect.
But that prompting in the time of the recording for the album was the Lord speaking to her heart.
So the very fact that you have
have this urge to repent is God speaking it.
If you don't act on that, he is gonna become very silent.
Number two, position yourself close to God.
I love this in first Samuel chapter three.
Samuel was lying down in the temple of the Lord where the Ark of God was.
He is as close as he can possibly be to the Lord's presence.
Proximity matters.
This is why church
is so important.
You just gotta decide what's gonna really be the value in your life.
What is really going to be pleasurable to your soul?
And if church becomes something you have to do instead of something you want to do, if church is an obligation to you instead of a benefit to you, then it's gonna be hard for you to show up at church.
But if church is a benefit, if you realize what God is doing in every single time, you're in His presence.
Then you say, you know, I want to be in your house.
Asama says, I love the habitation of your house, the place where your glory dwells.
And there's something about being in the presence of the Lord that changes us and transforms us as we go from glory to glory to glory.
You can literally position yourself in the presence of God.
Where's Eli?
He's in his usual place.
He's not even close.
This is why I would suggest it's really important to be in church.
I realize I'm preaching to the choir.
You're here, so congratulations.
You positioned yourself in the presence of the Lord, and that will have lasting impact on your life, your home, your family, your decisions, your job.
You're hearing the voice of the Lord long beyond tonight itself.
You're going to go out of here different than you came in Jesus' name because you honored God with the sacrifice of praise, because you honored God with the sacrifice of your time, because you honored God by saying, you're a priority in my life, and I'm telling you heaven notices that.
So if you want to hear the voice of God, be at church.
Be at the prayer meeting.
Be in a life group.
Have your regular time with the Lord.
Anytime there's an opportunity to get close to God, take it.
Listen to worship music.
Do the things that saturate your being with His presence and you will find yourself hearing His voice.
Number three, serve in the house of God.
I love this.
Here's Samuel.
The boy's Samuel was serving God under Eli's direction.
Most scholars think he's about eight years old at this time.
How much can an eight year old do?
Not a lot, but they can do something.
How much can you do?
Too many people are aware of what they can't do rather than what they can do.
And I just want to encourage you, there is something about serving.
It's not just sitting in his presence, but it's serving in his presence that really does increasingly open us up because now what happens if I'm just sitting in his presence, then I'm becoming a reservoir and I'm just receiving and I'm not giving and ultimately that will lead to stagnation in the life of a believer.
If all you are is give me, give me, give me, give me, and you're not releasing what God has done in your life, if you're not acting on the things that he's showing you, telling them to others and serving others, putting the Word of God into practice, not just being a hearer of the Word, but a doer of the Word.
When you start serving
things happen relative to God's voice.
The question is, are you serving in Go check?
Have you gone through Go check?
Are you serving on a dream team?
Are you in a life group?
Because I promise you this, you're going to hear the voice of God in that life group.
Say, what do you mean?
because you're gonna have heard the message, they're gonna be talking about the message.
And when they start talking, somebody is gonna say something you either did not hear or had not thought about that's gonna touch your heart in a profound way.
And that is the voice of God to you in that situation that you would not have had had you not been in that life group.
It's a very interesting thing.
Get around the people of God, serve the people of God, serve people.
Number four, listen for God's voice.
And when you sense his presence, respond.
Smith Wigglesworth was a man greatly used of God.
And on occasion he said this, I think this is a really profound concept.
When I catch the first breath of the Spirit, I leave everything and everybody to be in his presence, listen to this, to hear
What do you have to say to me?
Here's what he understood.
Sometimes you sense the presence of God, but that doesn't mean you just keep going.
It means you stop and you say, God, what are you trying to say to me?
My first encounter with this was I was in Panama with a missionary, and I told him I'd bring a team.
I kind of negotiated the deal.
This is a man who had done several 40-day fast.
He'd raised people from the dead.
And so when I meet people who or know of people who have that kind of powerful ministry, I want to learn from them.
So I said, I'll bring a team down if you'll promise me a day of your time.
So he agreed to that.
So we're with him and he's come off a
several days fast.
I don't remember how many days, but we'd be talking and all of a sudden you could sense the presence of the Lord come into the room and he'd say, let's pray.
And he was on his face on the floor crying out to God.
And then he'd get up like nothing had happened.
And he'd say, now where were we?
And then I mean, and I watched him through my time, I was down there for a week, and with him for more than just actually a day, but this was a common practice.
And he said, whenever I sense God's presence, I stop to listen to what God has to say.
I'm just saying there's something to what Smith Wigglesworth is saying, and you and I, we can
turn off, it's like we're turning a radio off if God's presence is there and we're not responding to His presence.
That's the time you say, well, man, I have a job.
I can't really do that.
You'll figure it out.
You will figure it out.
Hey, I'm gonna quickly use the restroom.
I don't know how you're gonna do it, but there's one idea.
You may say, well, anyway, you figured out.
The Lord will give you wisdom on that.
What's so sad here is that Eli knew exactly what Samuel was experiencing.
He knew what God's voice sounded like so he could tell Samuel how to respond to the voice of the Lord, but he wasn't near God's presence, so he wasn't listening for God's voice, so he didn't hear God's voice.
Here's another thing, it's possible to come to a place in your life where
You don't even care about God's voice.
You don't want to find tragic in this story.
One of the most tragic things is Eli knows God is speaking audibly, obviously, but he won't get up from where he is and walk to where God is.
You know, you just, you have to prioritize the voice of the Lord.
But Eli is, you know, you can get so far away from the Lord that you don't really care whether or not you hear the voice of the Lord.
And if you're indifferent to the Lord speaking to you, that should be a warning sign, a blaring siren and red light saying, you are in grave spiritual danger.
Number five, when God calls, respond eagerly.
Instead of debating in your mind, and I think one of the things that trips people up is they're like, well, what if I'm wrong?
What if it's not the voice of God?
My question is what if it is?
Let's quit talking about what if it's not?
What if it is?
And what happens is delay not only dulls the voice of the Spirit in our life,
But I would suggest to you that when God tells you to do something in that moment, there is a grace and a power on it that dissipates as you delay.
So that if God tells you to go pray for somebody, your greatest opportunity for impact in praying for them is immediately.
The longer you wait, the more
the presence and power of God dissipates.
Why?
Because what's functioning in your life is not faith but doubt.
We should understand that.
I mean, you're debating whether it's the voice of God.
Well, I don't know whether that's really God.
Do you realize what that is?
God has spoken, but now you're doubting.
If he's spoken, you say, no, I'm just trying to figure it out.
You don't have to figure it out.
Just obey.
God does not ask us to figure it out.
You say, but what if I'm wrong?
You are wrong.
If you think
If your deal is, I gotta be 100% every time, you know what?
You won't succeed at anything in life.
You know, you're gonna miss the mark.
If you're saying, I'm never gonna praise up for somebody until I know they're always gonna be healed.
You'll never pray for anybody and you won't see anybody healed.
The issue is, you're obedient to the Lord.
The Lord honors that obedience.
The Lord teaches you how to hear the voice of God and the person who, the more people you pray for, the more people you'll see healed.
The more you're listening and responding to the voice of the Lord, the more you're gonna hear the voice of the Lord.
Here's Samuel, he hears and he jumps up and he eagerly goes and he says, speak Lord, your servant is listening.
I'm ready, whatever you want me to do.
And God gives him word and says, you know what, you need to tell Eli this word the next morning.
It wasn't easy, it was difficult, but Samuel did it.
When God number six speaks, it's very similar, obey him.
You see this in Samuel's life later when he goes to anoint David.
The Lord said, fill your horn with oil and be on your way.
I'm sending you to Jesse of Bethlehem.
I've chosen one of his sons to be king.
And Samuel says, but if I go, Saul's going to hear about it.
He's going to kill me.
The Lord tells him what to do, but still there's a very great element of danger to Samuel personally.
But Samuel goes.
When Abraham hears God say, I want you to sacrifice your son Isaac, the next day he's on his way.
When God tells Abraham, I want you to go to a place I'm gonna show you and I'll tell you when you get there, so just start walking.
It says Abraham, Hebrews chapter 11 verse 8, when called to go to a place he would later receive his inheritance, obeyed and went, even though he did not know where he was going, the idea is while he was being called obeyed.
God was saying, I want you to go, Abraham's like, okay, let's go.
A several hundred mile journey, a massive relocation, no doubt with all the ramifications that you and I would have relative to family, friends, employment, livelihood, all those things.
To hear the voice of God, you've got to be committed to obeying the voice of God.
Dallas Willard in his book in search of guidance says this.
I think this is a tremendous insight.
Perhaps we don't hear the voice of God because we don't expect to hear it.
But perhaps we don't expect to hear it because we know that we fully intend to run our lives on our own and never seriously considered anything else.
The voice of God would therefore be an unwelcome intrusion into our plans.
Sometimes God doesn't speak because he knows you're not gonna do it anyway.
And what happens is when you and I obey what we're showing the Lord is, we're showing God, if you say it, I do it.
If you speak to me, I'm all about that.
Number seven, read and study God's word.
I think this is an interesting verse.
The Lord continued to appear at Shiloh.
Tabernacle was at that time.
And there he revealed himself to Samuel how through his word.
So what happens is the revelation of God comes to us through the word and then we also have God reveal himself through his voice and through a variety of ways.
But Samuel learns to hear God's voice by studying God's word.
Yes, God speaks through His Word, but we're not in a pursuit of knowledge, we're in a pursuit of relationship.
Because when people prioritize the acquisition of knowledge in their study of God's Word, they risk becoming a Pharisee.
Because invariably, Paul said this, 1 Corinthians 8, knowledge puffs up, love builds up.
And a lot of people, they study the word of God so they can win any debate.
And that's not the purpose.
The point of God's word is the revelation of God to us that we might know Him, that we might understand Him, that we might walk with Him, that we might love Him, that we might hear Him.
And why would God speak to you about his unreveiled will if you don't care about his revealed will, which is the word of God?
He's given us the word of God.
If you don't care about the thing he has spoken, why would he speak to you more things?
So what I'm saying, and what you're saying, anytime you pick up your Bible, you're saying, God, I really care about what you have to say.
I care so much.
I'm gonna read it.
I'm gonna study it because it reveals you to me.
His word makes him real to you.
I love talking to people who spend time, you know, our mother-in-law stays with us periodically.
And she's in the word and she talks about her reading like it just happened that day.
I'm not talking about her reading the Bible, but about the story she's reading.
I love that.
I love that about John Bonjourno.
He's sitting over there, he and Sandy.
John has gone through the Bible recently several times, five times a year, I think is what he does.
But he tells the story
Like it just happened yesterday.
It's like he just read it in the paper.
And I mean, it's real and it's alive and I love that.
And when the word of God becomes real to you like that, you're gonna hear his voice.
You're gonna know his leading.
You're gonna sense his prompting.
And so faith comes by hearing.
And what are we hearing?
The voice of God.
faith comes by hearing and hearing by what the Word of God.
You want to hear the voice of God getting the Word of God and you'll find God starting to speak to you a whole lot more than he ever has before and it will open you up to who he is and what he wants to do and how he wants to use you and direct you and it will make your life full.